now back tonight's other big story and
it's a major one the Jim Comey memos now
we now know what's in those memos and
now the Justice Department watchdog also
knows what's in those memos and now he
wants to investigate whether two of them
have leaked classified information on
the inside of them when he gave some of
those memos to his good buddy at
Columbia just uptown here who was at the
Justice Department Fox News chief
intelligence correspondent Catherine
Herridge is trying to stay up with this
but man this book tour is getting quite
interesting isn't it Catherine it is
Brian and thank you Fox News confirms
that Comey is under investigation by the
Justice Department's internal watchdog
the Inspector General for leaking the
memos whether he mishandled classified
information as well as his
communications outside the FBI including
reporters the memo showed the
relationship between the president and
Co me was difficult from the very
beginning after Comey briefed mr. Trump
about the dossiers unverified claims
just three weeks before the inauguration
those who support the president say the
memos show he wanted the Russia claims
investigated with Comey writing the
president said it would be good to find
out but that he hadn't done anything and
hoped I would find a way to get out that
we weren't investigating him president's
critics say another memo shows he
crossed the line when he talked with
Comey about a loyalty pledge Comey wrote
I replied that he would always get
honesty from me Trump paused and said
that's what he wants honest loyal t I
replied you will get that from me of the
15 pages of memos eight contained
classified information at the secret
which is highly sensitive or
confidential level and that seems to be
at odds with commis congressional
testimony after he was fired my thinking
was if I write it in such a way that I
don't include anything that would
trigger a classification that'll make it
easier for us to discuss within the FBI
and the government and to hold on to it
in a way that makes it accessible to us
but in this very first memo in January
of 2017 Comey knew his conversations
with the president were sensitive and
not public information I am not sure of
the proper classification here he wrote
so have chosen secret please let me know
if it should be higher or lower than
that so tonight we have a serious
investigation by the inspector general
at the Justice Department and another
apparent conflict between the document
and commis testimony Brian and it's you
know you can't say this is political or
president Trump's DOJ is in its it's an
Inspector General appointed by President
Obama correct that's correct
Kathryn great job you make it sound so
simple but yet we know it's really
complicated thank you meanwhile straight
ahead have a great weekend Catherine
Comey spoke about leaking the memos
during the interview with George
Stephanopoulos earlier this week you
know the interview that never ended take
a look presents tweeted innumerable
times calling you a leaker well what's
your response to President Trump
look it's true I mean I'm the one who
testified about it that's how people
know about it I gave it unclassified
memo to my friend and asked him to give
it to a reporter that is entirely
appropriate really in what world the
Wall Street Journal's editorial boards
member kremser wrassle one of her latest
columns is she talked about the
questions that she wants James Comey to
answer first off in it is it right for
him to have leaked that memo and his
reasoning is bizarre he says he I needed
to get the information into the public
square what is this 1778 yeah hi Brian
and no of course it's not appropriate
this is a man who has nailed to the wall
numerous people from his perch at the
FBI for having mishandled the classified
information for leaking he talks in his
memos about how he tells President Trump
he wants to go after the leakers make an
example of them and just because Jim
Comey decided that he was entitled to
take these documents which arguably by
the way our FBI property they were in
his possession and then decide that he
alone is entitled for the public
interest to leak everyone who leaks has
some sort of motivation like this and it
doesn't justify what he did he had four
memos out two of them they're taking
another look at meanwhile his deputy
Andy McCabe clearly is in trouble he
told multiple lies so he's going to be
secure we got to find out if these the
criminal referral will result in charges
but looking at Comey in particular I
have a little problem for example his
pull aside in the Oval Office that is
very similar to the pull aside in Trump
Tower you have a new person into
politics who's used to running a major
organization and wants to have a
confidential conversation if you know
more about how
son how about this Jim called me instead
of jotting it down after you leave hey
mr. president no offense I'm sure you
don't realize I shouldn't really be
one-on-one with you let's get somebody
else in the room for your own you know
just so you don't have a problem later
there are so many ways to avoid the
problem instead we hear about the voice
in his head and he writes in longhand
and we eventually get a best-selling
book there does seem to be almost a
sense of entrapment in these memos as
though he was urging the President to do
things so that he could then run back
outside and write down the bad things
the president had done in his mind and
by the way the double standard here to
Brian I think is glaringly evident Jim
Comey tells us in his book and on this
tour about the doubts he had about
Loretta Lynch and her judgment some of
the orders she gave him but do we have
any conversations between him and her
that were memorialized absolutely not so
I mean and there's a lot of other things
that come out of this memo too I think
we're finding as well that Jim Comey he
likes to talk about how he's just a fax
guy but again only the facts that matter
and once we're seeing the context of a
lot of these statements that have been
wafting around in the press for the last
year it turns out there's a very
different reading of this than the one
that only Jim Comey was giving us up
until now it's unbelievable I just think
that if he had any brains in his head
one interview and get off the stage the
more he talks the more news unfolds the
more he backs himself into a corner and
now his battles with Andy McCabe because
they both can't be telling the truth
because both their stories diverge
Caribou I look forward to your next
article I'll talk to you again soon